well
[Music]
how are you greetings cristian cásseres with
his brief news now in
spanish the famous magician safe and facebook
of the legendary sex and
android show passed away he was 81 years
old and died last night at his residence in
las vegas after a long  battle against
pancreatic cancer
the duo revolutionized entertainment
here in las vegas with their
brunch show that began in 1990 their
career was halted by a
tiger attack during one of their performances
in 2003 when he spoke and nearly lost his
life roy  passed away from
coronavirus complications last year
and the first mega vaccination site
opens its doors today in southern nevada
this requires an appointment but many
criticize the system after a saturation
of
the south nevada health district website people  70
years and older can request an appointment
but only
first aid workers and appointments will be able to
get vaccinated at this time in the jazm  ín
sánchez and we receive new details
about a shooting that occurred during the
early hours of the morning in the northeast of the valley the
metropolitan police continue to search for the
suspect officers report that a
person was shot multiple times
near skyscanner by drive and highway
95 the gunman escaped and by  The victim's condition is unknown at this time
and the Clark County School District
will meet today to discuss whether to
return students to classrooms
Administrators propose to have small groups of
students who
voluntarily want to return to
campus Original plan was
presented to the Board  board as
the first step in transitioning to
virtual learning and finally moving on
with a preview of temperatures for
our region the day will be clear
with highs reaching
almost 70 degrees we will see
pleasant conditions
continue for several days until a
wave  cold return during the
This is how we end this weekend
briefing on News Now in Spanish. I'm
Cristian Cásseres. Happy Thursday
[Music]